Узимку в Гельсінкі зранку ще так темно
що Татьяна Вало щоразу навіть трохи радіє
своєму яскраво освітленому робочому місцю
Щоправда, денного світла вона тут не побачить навіть удень
Жінка працює під землею
в підземному басейні
Коли відвідувачі приходять до нас уперше,
то запитують
а як ви тут працюєте, зовсім без вікон?
Але це просто питання звички
Тут у нас завжди однаковий клімат
байдуже, світить зверху сонце чи йде дощ
Відвідувачі вже теж давно звикли
до підземного басейну
який на випадок війни може слугувати бомбосховищем
Я приходжу тільки восени і взимку
Влітку я плаваю на свіжому повітрі, в озерах
Фінська столиця може запропонувати гостям
багато цікавого
Але найцікавіше можна побачити лише, якщо спустишся вниз, у скелясте підземелля
Нині там створюють друге місто
Зі своїми торговими центрами, вокзалами
А зовсім недавно відкрили художній музей
площею 2200 квадратних метрів
У той час, як інші великі міста ростуть угору
Ейя Ківілааксто риє вглиб
Головна архітекторка Гельсінкі хоче таким чином
вирішити проблему нестачі місця
в центрі фінської столиці
Дев'ять мільйонів кубічних метрів
мають забудувати під землею до 2020 року
Все, для чого не потрібне денне світло
можна розташувати внизу, така ідея
Ми в Гельсінкі вже давно використовуємо
підземну частину міста
щоб розмістити там частину інфраструктури, наприклад, для транспорту
При цьому ми виявили, що для інших цілей
це теж ідеальне місце,
наприклад, для обчислювальних центрів
Адже під землею завжди одна і та ж температура
Фінську архітекторку дивує
що в німецькому Штутгарті люди роками виступали
проти запланованого підземного вокзалу
У Гельсінкі ніхто не був би проти
У нас ще жодного разу не було демонстрацій
проти підземного проекту
Проте були протести проти висоток
Сухий клімат під землею
подобається і Вейкко Косонену
Пенсіонер готується до змагань
разом зі своїм клубом
зовсім недалеко від містобудівного відомства
Це один з кількох підземних
спортивних комплексів Гельсінкі
Якщо не брати до уваги відлуння, то тут,
у тунелі, все дуже добре
Нема різниці, що відбувається нагорі
Тут унизу завжди однаково тепло,
все добре провітрюється
За температуру в тунелі відповідає новітня установка
з регенерації теплової енергії
Тепло відпрацьованої води використовується для побутових потреб над землею
Це добре для енергоефективності
У співробітниці басейну Татьяни Вало
закінчився робочий день
Під землею вона більше сумує за свіжим повітрям
аніж за слабким денним світлом узимку
Унизу біля басейну температура іноді досягає 38 градусів при високій вологості
І це вибиває з колії. Як у сауні
Адже під землею не відкриєш вікна,
щоб провітрити
Але підземне будівництво в Гельсінкі
це не зупинить